[Musica]
benvenuti solita striscioni nuovissimo
reparto da solo dovremo fare dall'hotel
infestata di fantasmi realtà sono tante
altre attori paurose qua infatti tre di
fantasmi storie alienazione seminterrato
quanto mi piace perché questo video
raggiunge i 10 mila mi piace faremo
un'altra di queste storie paurose
quale storie parliamo oggi verrà troppo
divertente sapete che adoriamo le cose
paurosa
prendetevi preferiscono i concorrenti
factor in causa mitomane scendiamo
allora dice che dobbiamo scegliere uno
degli ascensori torres è una storia di
fantasmi una storia aliena è una storia
seminterrato direi di iniziare con i
fantasmi di fantasmi e poi è stato mi
piace se volete vedere le altre due
storie poi entra si ha il coraggio di
certo dove sei leader dentro le storie
di fantasmi ok arrivo ok sono entrati
nella sensore su indecisione siamo
tantissimi quattro fogli di fantasmi
ci sono anch'io guardi se le cose
prodotti
e sono qui a roma non prepariamo ti
rimane moka e medicine ok ho trovato
qualcosa qui da noi via per un
termosifone e la stampa andiamo in
camera nostra dice qualcuno cammina per
il corridoio fa aprì le porte cento
perché hai questa città questa non si
apra una fiction sicura
pietrificato
sei cassette da me assordato tipo cosa
dico io proprio permettere ad aria
condizionata fa un po di freddo qui
detto
nessuna porta si no il numero distanza
enti già qualcuno
camera 113 unità ha vinto il premio tiny
hotel guarda che non prendo queste porte
ma sono sempre più visto la stanza
microscopica dentro vedi gli ho uno dei
mini tavoli mini lampade uisp ad entrare
nel nostro ma da nulla dice di andare
alla stanza 113 possiamo dar finalmente
possiamo dormire un po ok qualcosa che
non quadra
decisi insomma è in festa per succedere
qualcosa
stanno arrivando i fantasmi la pioggia
per primavera tutto ha qualcosa a che
fare alla piazza ma forse era l'anno
accordata è no il pulmino e mi ha
spaventato e formine ma c'era anche un
lascia che sia luce possiamo dividerci è
tornata alla luce così quel biglietto
sul muro di un euro ecco qui c'è un
biglietto qualsiasi iscritto clicca su
nota mai dei fantasmi posso aiutarti 55
56 3 2 0 ma chi sono i ghostbusters che
vogliono gli acchiappafantasmi forte
risponde al telefono io comporre il
numero ei reati va a prendere il tema è
tutto arrivando kg quello che abbiamo
chiamato forza la cappa fantasma e come
fa sapere dove siamo
2k fantasmi c'entra qualcosa secondo me
di nuovo andato via da luce
ok aprì la porta attento non si fanno la
porta
siamo ad aprire solo quando vediamo chi
è
[Applauso]
appreso vitale
[Risate]
che vita è tornato per miracolo
io no erano troppo a quel fantasma
abbiamo mangiato vita so se sono qui per
risolvere i suoi problemi poiché marmi
cacciatori di fantasmi di gates da
saperlo che si entravano i ghostbusters
veramente stavamo solo come possa
arrivare qui così in fretta se lui è il
fantasma mi sembra che i sospetti
fossero corretti ma non ho risposte si
rilevano alti livelli di lettura e
spirituali in questo hotel molto bene
spirituale livello alto questo tele
pestato bel avevamo capito trova
precisamente vieni con me dobbiamo
mettere a riposo queste anime avrò
bisogno del tuo aiuto o questi shooter
speciali spinti shooter l'unica cosa è
mi mancano un paio di batterie per loro
dobbiamo cercare delle batterie allora
ti dovessero ripostiglio qui intorno
potreste portarvi delle batterie ok
cerchiamo le bacia miracolo
appassioniamo si prima che torni
qualcosa sono 34 mila tep ragazza ne ha
trovate subito bravo come prendo una a
una alla volta sono gravi io c'ero 1 e
capitano eccellente questi sono perfetti
che bello era che vanno nel coso chi ha
commentato che usa questi spirit su the
fare esplodere fantasmi in un'altra
dimensione avuto alcun cautela ok
attento se vedi uno di quei fantasmi
sfacelo che sta sparando io non sparo di
ammettere che stava sparendo m
dobbiamo bere bene ecco lo sai
non sarà così basta avete visto prima
pole prima lo hanno festeggiato come mai
questo fantasma o che lucra su ok perché
sta piangendo vogliono tre motori di
fantasmi del lavoro non che avessi paura
o qualcosa del genere
mentre lei brava mica tecnici isolamento
e penso che ora dobbiamo cercare gli
altri fantasmi cos'era quello
sta arrivando un fabbro non mi dire che
siamo morti turnover ovale evocando
digiuno il parcheggio dove siamo e
restiamo uniti sembra che siamo caduti
nel parcheggio dell'hotel faremmo meglio
a trovare un modo per tornare indietro
ok questo è scritto uscita aiuto
c'è infatti solo di lando delle
letterate di chieti dove pronti a sparar
lì
dove
finiscono dove continua a piangere ma
insomma più caldo ma 30 33 pap dove sono
ok ho preso uno ok forse ce l'abbiamo
tolta i fantasmi fanno paura di fantasmi
g
ma potreste aiutarci invece di stare lì
a piangere infatti nel far meglio
sbrigarsi
devo andare ho ricevuto rapporti che i
fantasmi stanno causando problemi
all'hotel nella cucina dell'hotel allora
dobbiamo andare nella cucina dell'hotel
questa è la mia macchina come con la
macchina andiamo qual è la macchina sarà
questa blu possiamo tornare all hotel
con la mia macchina possiamo prendere
l'ascensore alla zucca ho come
l'impressione che una delle due scelte
vabbè andiamo andiamo con la madre
speriamo che non si
può dimostrare scelta
la macchina il vento è sormontato da
pachino 7 tutto un ascensore prossima
per fortuna mia macchina non è regolò
mica
è così ora dobbiamo andare nella cucina
si sono ammalati di fantasmi che no no
no perché sembravano fantasmi o non ho
dimenticato di menzionare una cosa la
cosa
che cosa è alto quando l'ascensore
dovremmo prendere le scale da qui quindi
chi è alto quanto era settore queste
sono infestate e state attenti
vai avanti come vai avanti leva sulle
scale ma ecco le date sono così scomode
o le scale stato cambiato alle scale
piace cambiare da che film tratta questa
frase come vedremo i compensi scritto
questa lettera studiamo rientrante pirlo
ma quindi bisogna saltare nelle scale
quando arrivano ma seccati giu e la fine
a ok stai molto attento
non sono sicuro di farcela io qui dai
cui carcere in quanto vi sono le scale
poi arrivano le altre scale quindi
aspetta che arrivino le altre sono
dietro di te dai si spengono casini
manca solo l'ultima troppo bravissimo
siamo rimasti torna in due ho notato a
queste si schiaccia motivo sede è
decaduta purtroppo io sono morto non
riuscivo a rivivere e si è bloccato
tutto e sono tornata alla lobby quindi
non posso più stare in un gioco di
evitare per cominciare tutto daccapo
quindi continueremo il gioco dati sono
di vitale finché sopravvivere e
sembriamo anno tentò è sì ho tempo forse
la mia saltare arrivate altre sei
rimasto solo tu
tributo vitalità sono
anche più quel ghost buster potevo
farcela sconfiggere questi fantasmi ma
dove sarà finito quello lirico master
non lo sono che piange sempre crisi
forse l'atleta ha raggiunto
la cima per evitare questa è la fine non
farsi distrarre dal cibo mi fanno
giornale le gambe per portarci a quanto
mangerai passi non entra forse bisogna
aspettare il cost master si che qui che
lavora tutti ma come a tutti nessuno io
siamo riusciti a raggiungere il
ristorante siamo andare a mangiare
benvenuto ok faccia un po triste questo
cammino
ti prego vieni con me dice simone questo
è il nostro cibo ma qualcuno dei
fantasmi sta mangiando non pagare la
bolletta sono gli spaghetti però a tu x
affamati vogliono di più vi sono
scappato tanti ma ce la farò io adesso
da solo a sconfiggerlo deve fare mi
dispiace non mi pagano abbastanza per
questo vado via da quel porto la cui
morte non capitolo tra l'altro sembra
proprio lo slime i loro nomi al majid
alla morte
ma mi sta insegnando
sta per caldo danni più difficile è che
non ti aiuta ma devo fare tutto da solo
totti non è per niente facile
passa
preso
dobbiamo andare in cucina aspetta che
ricarico prima in cucina c'è un altro
slimer si pensa che sto ricaricando così
è tutta questa roba o no infatti tutto
verde guarda è meglio non entrare laden
tra fantasma ha lasciato una barricata
di mia ma ci dà
una lumaca prova a farlo esplodere con
le tue armi ok allontanati allontanati
ma ora ma rimane lontano nel caso che
esplodano ma dimostrare che coinvolte
ascolto aspetto mi sto ricaricando
[Applauso]
[Musica]
spaghetti pasta yum yum gustoso mangiare
io resto qui fatta la famiglia non può
risale prego aiutateci quella cosa
continua a mangiare tutto quello che
facciamo sono
se ci sei tu sei stati falsati schifose
l'hotel dista arrabbiando chi interrompe
la
ragazza che dovrei sconfiggere questo
anche questo da solo o non è più
super affamato dare cibo siamo io e
mangiato anche le serie a
napoli
pensa sia molto arrabbiato molto è
ok questa è l'ultima chance che abbiamo
visto secondo le tesi attentamente
paradosso delle pagine questo secolare
caricando praticamente prende le tesi
essere butta addosso capito
o forse di vista come pietro si fa a
colpirlo da dietro non ho ancora non
l'ho ancora preso in più di molto troppo
difficile
sfida di molte funzioni non volumi
tirare cosa addosso devi devi sempre
scappare trash difficilissimo da solo un
filo i tavoli addosso
e così tornati alla loro fisico ma non
siamo riusciti a completare la storia di
fantasmi proviamo ad andare nella storia
seminterrato ma
quando siamo in tre per il momento 3 dai
venite qua sta arrivando parco si
fa niente ok siamo ma è uguale all hotel
di prima sbagliato vuole che differenza
c'è lo dovrebbe essere uno scantinato ma
è il quale allora
vediamo cosa succede dove siamo cosa è
successo ieri sera
ieri sera io non lo so dico forse
dovremmo dare un'occhiata in giro ottima
terapie già controllato tutto non sei
niente di strano cerca nella stanza
degli indizi su cosa è successo sembra
che nessuno sembra ricordare ieri sera
quasi un biglietto dove vediamo un po in
bagno ho visto qualcosa ieri sereno il
corridoio non so cosa fosse ma di sicuro
non era un mano
vincere
ok andiamo di controllare
che cosa hai fatto ma spetta ai sentito
bercy dire
scusate signori l'hotel am ha emesso un
evocazione di emergenza non aprire non
aprire una trappola come prima prima è
vero ti ha mangiato devo chiederti di
aprire la porta e manda ma l'onda nati
proprio dalla prova il microscopio sotto
il letto qualcuno non avrà la porta
prende la porta come prende la porta ma
la caprine no
che questo ciao sono il fattorino
dell'hotel ma poiché a chiamarmi signor
smith
sarei la tua scorta dobbiamo andarcene
subito perché che cosa è successo spiega
mi hai sentito l'urlo proprio ora
parlare proprio di colonizzarlo in un
momento come questo dobbiamo solo fare
come dice l'hotel
da un complice c'è qualcosa di strano
seguitemi tutti dobbiamo assicurarci che
tutti siano al sicuro ok andiamo ci
prendiamo un momento per controllare le
camere qualcosa si sente fuori ok
controlliamo le camere ma sicuramente
sia una camera aperta
non so cosa troveremo però
la numero 108 credo ci sia qualcuno qui
dentro controlliamo
e qualcuno moto
è successo un crimine come forse dovevo
risolvere un crimine così la pistola ma
c'è un messaggio nel leggere il
messaggio
che se successo andata via la luce ma
deve bere un'acqua
indagare sulla strana loro io uso questo
c'è scritto aiuto
lo script aiuto non è molto generoso un
indizio vediamo se c'è qualche altro
indizio po in giro oh mio dio è morta ad
esso tende a cortona per l'acqua da bart
ad ora non so chi era molto sfortunato
questa pistola potrebbe essere utile
raccoglierlo ok raccogliamola chi l'ha
presa presa secondo me è stato mister
smith
lavorare un tappeto fondi al telefono
ei protette non mi fa rispondere e
non hanno sparato forse qualcuno li è
andata via la luce
[Musica]
no perché se una morta
non lo so dobbiamo tacere subito dico io
forse lei che mi è uscita con la
situazione in erba dobbiamo fare
prenditi un momento per discutere della
tua prossima mossa
eccoci
apre isolato che l'ascensore fosse in
fondo al corridoio molto bella che
l'ascensore anche signor smith non stato
ad andare saranno altri fantasmi
a me fa più paura questa giocatrice che
sbaglia tutto
forse oltre questa porta dove sta
scritto che porta tavole chiesa a
chiamare i muri che stanno avvicinando
quali muri
cento sbrigati trova la chiave dovrebbe
essere uno di questi corridoi ok io vedo
49 ma è bloccato equa presto no sono
tutti bloccati dividiamo sia controllo
nei corridoi allora io vado in questo ma
sotto le che bloccati da questa notte
dai sbrigati
non hanno colpito pure a me no vabbè
abbiamo porti subito ma stanno
difficilissima questi prum dell'hotel
impes taio però se questo è evidente di
10 mila mi piace proveremo anche quella
aliena proveremo a non minare questa è
quindi lasciate baby piacere e ora vi
lasciamo qualcosa adesso il leader qui
cliccare per vedere i dotti altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite buona
vita